Can a zeolite product be helpful for someone fighting cancer?
Sure, so zeolite is not a cancer killer. No, but zeolite
It functions actually as a binder and as a key later because you do absorb zeolite
So it does function as a key later too. So keylating
X and 7 phase of detox is phase 0. So again, you have to make sure you're supported
All those other phases before you start taking zeolite or edta or dms a which is those are more heavy keylators
So but yes, yeah keylating toxins out of your body can be very beneficial
So if you're having supporting the liver and making sure you're in a bowel movement you're doing coffee
And of us and things like that supporting bile flow supporting your gallbladder
Using hot packs over your liver using keylators by all beads can be extremely helpful with anybody with any health condition
Is it going to be a cancer killer to kill cancer cells in my opinion?
No, no not at all, but
You're not just trying to kill cancer cells. You're trying to take burdens off your body
So your immune system can kill cancer cells. So
all those things
You don't just treat the cancer you treat the person which you know
Maybe has cancer because of toxins, which is the number one cause of cancer. So remember
Cancer is anything that
caused by anything gets inside the cell and damages the DNA replication when it goes into rapid replication
That is by definition what cancer is it's that's an outside cell. It's your own cell
That is in rapid replication is replicating damaged DNA that are replicating damaged DNA
And you got this rapid replication of cells. You get this growing mass
That's continuing to replicate
And most commonly you know, you can't have a myotoxin cause, but most commonly it's a it's a toxic cause
So something gets inside that cell
and
Cause that replication to take place. So
You know detoxification has got to be a part of that person's healing for sure
so
using
ZO light can be a good
Way to help with that